[Music]
manisa is with us in austin texas hi
menissa how are you
hi dave i'm doing good how you doing
better than i deserve what's up
so i was calling because um you don't
know this but you your books helped me
to get out of credit card debt good for
you yeah thank you i started with my by
myself trying to to take care of myself
and then i showed my my parents but they
were skeptics i mean my mom finally got
on board and then my dad got on board so
we we no longer have credit cards yet um
however now we're in the dilemma where
the house that we purchased
was a wreck so we had to sell it to an
investor and we're in limbo we don't
have
anywhere to
go
the housing market is so bad we keep
getting outbid for houses
and we tried buying a trailer house and
there's issue with land so
i'm i'm thinking i needed to go there
regularly too to find out how do i
invest so that i can
build my wealth i i know
you're one of one of the sections in
your books is to
get an emergency fund
and then do 401 of course i had already
had my 401
and
but i for some reason i can't get the
thousand dollars
i can't even get a hundred dollars and i
don't know what that is so i was hoping
maybe you can leave me in the right
direction okay uh who's we
your parents and you are doing all this
together
yes i try to do it on my own like i said
i read the book i mean i mean you're
like you're like the house you own you
own with your parents
yes we did but we we had to sell it
because it was so it's sold so you don't
currently own a house with your parents
no sir we were trying to buy good don't
don't don't own a house with your
parents how old are you
i'm 52. don't own a house with your
parents
well
they need me
well they they can get a place to rent
you can help take care of them but you
don't need to own a house with your
parents that's a this is a bad plan
yeah i completely agree with you okay
good then don't do it they agree with
you yeah so how much of the money did
you get money from the sale of the other
property
um because we had to sell to a home
investor we didn't really get that much
but we have 15 000
you have how much um
15 000 okay and so you have 7 500 for
them and 7 500 for you right
i will they can have all of it i i mean
you're going to give them all of it okay
then what do you make a year
um
about 41 000 okay and how did you get
out of debt
we just
did your baby steps
well that's baby step one's a thousand
dollars you said you couldn't do that
well then like we we that so i've been
trying to to do that but every time
something comes up that we need to start
getting the money out okay there's not a
win you're 52.
there's a them and a you
yes there's no we
yes sir okay so you make 41 000 a year
and how did you pay off credit card debt
well um
so
you got on a budget and you found money
in the budget and you put it on the
credit cards right
well uh what i did was that we took all
of the bills and the one that was the
lowest we just split the
the balance three ways and we we paid
that and then we paid
we did that for each one of the bills
until we got them all paid off
okay
all right so you found the money in your
personal income to apply to the debt
correct yes yes sir so that's how you do
your thousand dollars
only now it's going to be you and you
need to go find an inexpensive place to
rent give them the 15 000 set up your
life and begin to work the baby steps
with a written budget you're not doing a
budget
and you need to start doing a budget
immediately
so get on every dollar and download the
the world's best budgeting app and get
your get your budget going to where you
are doing this but money say you have to
separate
you can love mom and dad
but you're 52 years old time to move out
of your mother's basement
time to quit sharing bills with your mom
and dad it is way past time unless you
have some kind of a a mental disorder
that doesn't enable you to live on your
own
but you need to do that and you need to
do it now and i don't think you do based
on talking to you yeah i i would just
add one thing when he said i want you to
ask yourself
you said they need me
but i wonder how much you need them and
you're not even aware of how much
they're a safety net for you for you not
to truly fly and to do what you're
supposed to be doing i think you've got
to really confront that i think at 52
it's time as dave said for you to strike
out and do your own thing and at 41 000
a year you can get that a thousand
dollar emergency fund pretty quickly
yeah and move through this and before
you know it
be truly in a great place financially
get the least expensive thing don't buy
a trailer
they go down in value get the least
expensive thing you can get to rent get
yourself started get and take all the
extra jobs you can take and get on a
written budget and begin to build the
thousand dollars and then work your way
on up through all of the baby steps and
you'll be just fine you can do this